good morning i hope you had a good
night's sleep it's just another day
where the review system in machine
learning is completely
and utterly broken this time courtesy of
the icml
chairs apparently notifying the
senior area chairs to reduce the
number of accepted submissions by about
10 percent
according to current meta review
statistics we need to raise the
acceptance bar
also saying we plan to reduce the number
of accepted papers
please work with your senior area chair
to raise the bar
area chairs and senior area chairs do
not have to accept a paper only because
there is nothing wrong with it
so the icml conference is trying to
raise the bar
on scientific publication in their venue
by just accepting a little bit less
papers than they
would do according to current trajectory
of the review process
icml currently is in the post
review post rebuttal process where the
actual acceptance decisions are made
now why is this important this is
important because there are only about
three or four large conferences in
machine learning
each year depending on your subfield bit
more
or even a bit less for many places if
you want to get a phd if you want to get
tenure if you want to achieve anything
in academia
you need to publish papers at those
venues and given that the field
is exploding currently getting a paper
there
is quite difficult acceptance rates
have been dropping steadily in the past
few years
though you can see the number of
accepted papers has actually
risen this is a consequence of the
exponential growth
of the machine learning field now
there's a growing concern
that the review process isn't really
good
and what gets published and what doesn't
get published is just kind of a wash and
the noisy process which is true i've
made
quite a number of videos about the
really flawed
review process in machine learning
essentially
here is what we know if your paper is
really good then
it's going to get accepted very probably
you might get unlucky
but with a high probability it's going
to get there if your paper is really bad
also with a high probability it's going
to get rejected
however for most papers which aren't
extremely good
which aren't extremely bad there's just
this middle area most papers fall into
this middle
area and it's really a
roll of a dice you get some reviewers
they might know what they're talking
about they might not know what they're
talking about they have their favorite
data set you didn't evaluate on it
they reject or they weak accept because
they just don't want to deal with your
rebuttal
it's an all-around fun process but it
can ruin your life
and for a conference such as icml it is
important that it keeps up its
reputation for only publishing
the best papers and really good
scientific results so by reducing the
acceptance rate
what they'll do is they'll put more
focus on the really good papers that
stand out
which can be interpreted as a good thing
because ultimately
the really good papers will still stay
while some of the borderline papers will
drop out
that gives you a stronger signal that
whatever comes from this conference
is a valuable scientific publication on
the other hand you can say given
how noisy that review process is you
simply compress a little bit the amount
of people that draw a lucky lottery
ticket and given that the field is
growing and there is huge
pressure on people to publish and also
the fact that
large corporations throw extreme amounts
of money
of getting papers published at these
conferences weeding out
the academics that don't have as much
resources
it is a bit of a controversial decision
essentially reviewers and area chairs
are even more incentivized to just find
anything wrong with a paper
and reject it because of it and the
downside of that
is that if you don't have as much
resources to train on every data set
you're probably going to be out much
more likely and also if you have some
really cool idea that just
doesn't work yet quite well doesn't beat
state of the art yet but
is quite interesting also very probably
you're not gonna get there
so while the optimist might see a
stronger signal
for an acceptance rating at that
conference and
just higher quality output and the
pessimist
might see the noisy process and say well
what is it all worth it doesn't mean
anything to get accepted anyway and now
it's just less papers that do
and also large companies are going to
dominate the field and also academics
are going to
draw the short stick the optimist and
the pessimist are no match
for the phd student see what they seem
to be doing right here
is specify the acceptance their target
in percent which means number of
accepted papers
divided by number of submitted papers i
hope you see
where this is going the target
acceptance rate in the eyes of the
conference means that
the numerator should be smaller however
you can reach that same acceptance
rate by just making the denominator
larger
now hypothetically if just everyone
would submit
more papers we could drop the acceptance
rate
but also raise the chances that our
actual papers are going to get in
now in this hypothetical scenario i
would not be advocating
for submitting fake papers or just
empty pdfs but you might have some
papers
in the drawer like this beauty right
here
that i wrote back in i don't know when
where i designed the method to defend
against
blackbox model theft attacks which i
thought was pretty smart but
honestly it needs a lot of work to
actually
make it work and i just did not bother
it's an archive right now but even
though i am not happy with it
as it is it is certainly better than a
lot of stuff that i've seen submitted to
icml
that i've read as a reviewer and even
some stuff that actually got accepted at
the end so compared to that i don't see
a reason why
this should not be worthy so
you my friend are going to icml
next year how about that
of course all just a hypothetical uh i'm
not advocating for you to
mess with a system that's clearly broken
and needs to be
renewed and we should reinvent the whole
thing
however it's fun to think about
if you have some thoughts on
hypothetical scenarios
or stories about how your papers got
rejected that we
all love to tell tell me in the comments
and
see you next time
[Music]
so
you